it sorry is good sex not what makes you
feel good if you're lacking out your
feeling then you're gonna deem it as
good sex regardless if so yeah I think
what everyone deems as good sex is some
people say that oh when you have sex
with the first but someone with the
first time it's not necessarily great
but as you get to know each other's body
it becomes better so then I don't think
you need to be exposed so much you just
have to understand each other and have
that connection so don't you think it's
better to do that with one person and
then have multiple experiences then yeah
yeah 100 yeah yeah I don't think you
need to sleep with many people no
definitely not and in terms of like a
sexual connection as well like you could
have sex with someone who's amazing in
bed
um and maybe it's not treating you as
good as someone else or that you have a
stronger chemistry with and he's not as
good as bad but I think as a woman you
will emotionally connect with a person
who's not as good yeah you want to go
out of the Good Wood
I think we will I think we will Overlook
that when a girl gets hypnotized
is it the same for men or no like do men
um if men slept with left less women
would they be oh is that yeah
statistically um so the the best
outcomes is when they're both virgins
okay so that's that's one thing I think
sometimes like people gloss over however
um a man that slept with around eight or
nine if I remember correctly
um Partners versus three is happier in
his marriage okay so actually men's
happiness goes up at some point rather
than down when they've slept with more
people and I think it kind of goes back
to like like a lot of things like I
guess red pill truths are kind of known
in society like before but they would
say men would go sew their Wild Oats and
then go get a wife hmm
but yeah the more people a woman slept
with decrease I have a question for the
panel how many times have you fallen in
love
once once once once
I don't know if I have you know I don't
think I have evil
um
I'm full in love before
um
I feel like I've experienced different
types of Love though you see you haven't
fallen in love no I have you have okay
yeah but
I was 16 and she was like 20.
she was my substitute teacher
I think it's infatuation yeah
she might still be able to get me maybe
she looked the same I don't know
the idea of Defending up with the idea
the way I envisioned her like she was my
queen
the first time I got drunken [ __ ] they
say that man like it's kind of weird
like every girl that they've been in
love with they kind of like love them
forever in like a weird way that women
won't understand because we only love
one guy at a time that's right say that
again it's like I've heard this I'm I'm
butchering it but basically like men can
love multiple women at the same time and
so like there'll be a lot of times it's
a common story like oh he's still in
love with his high school girlfriend or
High School something and like it's an
archetype that I've just heard over and
over again and it's like man when they
fall in love with someone it's like
they're in love with them forever and
like women won't understand that but
then what about the the idea that a
woman who's had multiple partners is
still loving her ex well that's that's
because that was the best she could do
so like I mean historically women ended
up with the best guy they could be with
because otherwise their husband would
get killed and she'd get taken by the
bus guy I mean that's why women this is
an uncomfortable this is an
uncomfortable truth but the number one
requested
um like
Rico we had a male only fans model on
the show and the number one thing women
request is grape that's great wow yeah
that's crazy yeah and I and like like
why do women like being like choked why
do women like yo it's because like
biologically they they kind of ah I
don't know
why do girls like the handmaid's tale
when women love that show
my adult experience the woman who has
been the most dominant and successful
Mexican at work is the one who wants to
be utterly dominated at home yeah okay
so I think um like that I like I like to
feel like someone else is in control
yeah right but it's because I feel like
in my whole life I've had to be in
charge and I don't like it so I'd like
to come home and know that I can put all
my man could just chokey no
oh well you talk about sexually I was
talking about sexually oh because well
because that's what you were saying
right you said about early months for
modeling that yeah yeah it's like like
so so I was saying like women want to be
with the best the guy they could
historically because we we would be but
now it's it's not like that and so like
if a girl experiences experience as a
guy that's like too high like she'll
think about him forever and you and you
all know you have a friend that always
runs back to that same EX
I think that's why that's why they got
like we were talking about twin flames
before you know you know the thing about
like the love and being a love thing and
always have enough for that person I
think that goes for men and women they
you know they're saying they say the
first love Cuts deep and I I or the
first love is very deep and I think for
men and women because like we've been
having this conversation the other day
that the first guy that goes with right
that she basically has her everything
like the sex with him and emotional or
whatever right almost a lot of guys
after that are almost a different like
an archetype of that guy because it's
like the first love is almost like an
imprint it's like it's like the first
the I've heard this song guy had a
theory on this and I'm curious if the
girls think this is true so first first
three guys that a girl sleeps with the
best sass out of the three that's her
type forever
I think your type changes over time as
you evolve over time right like you
learn more about yourself what you like
what you don't like would you would you
say um the older you've gotten like how
has your type changed you go for like
the bad boys you know like the guys that
used to treat me like [ __ ] and then as I
got older I was like oh they treat me
like [ __ ] so like my change has
completely changed like I go for
different looks complete I go from more
personality you know like what do you
mean for like the the sexual part like
comparatively between the good guy and
the bad guy as your as your preference
in bed change as well
okay yeah I feel like don't you feel
like you can only get y Zone all of this
stuff by experience so did you have to
date different type of guys to know what
you don't want 100 yeah
yeah
that's but see this is like the common
company of man is that women give their
best years to guys that are bad and then
expect them to pick up the pieces after
when people say that um
I think my best year well forget about
the your beliefs of Virgin and all of
that but I found my voice
traits and my personality and how I met
hiring myself and everything I'm a
better woman now yeah so yeah but yeah
okay she's saying to her so yeah to
yourself if you're basing it if you're
basing it on
um
me being a single mom and all of that
stuff then yes no matter what I do I may
not but if someone was to take the
chance to get to know me now
and got to know me a man gets to know me
back then he would prefer the woman he
would be more willing to get to listen
to hear me out now than he would back
then and that's even when I was with no
kids single and whatever and you you
might be like a more agreeable woman now
would you say that's true I'm a what
agreeable like a real ball kind of goes
with femininity like maybe you're more
feminine now oh 100 yeah and so like
that might be true but like what gets
you in the door is like looks Youth and
kids are no kids because it's like like
a guy has a checklist of things here
yeah 100 and so it's like you're not in
the same doors no well I would like I
think I think there's qualities that
attract a man and there's qualities that
keep Superman yeah I know and correct me
if I'm wrong I think you're saying the
qualities that you have that will keep
in mind now is superior than what you
had before yeah but I think what almost
they're saying is that maybe the quality
is to attract the man maybe it's a
little bit lower than it was before but
I do think that a man will compromise on
the
attractive qualities for the right
keeping quality I mean I don't say like
all hope like my my sister was a single
mother and she got married too I would
say she did better than her baby daddy
but like I I think it was an exception
it's not the rule why would you I would
add that men are probably more likely to
tolerate bad characteristics
for women to have less baggage because
it's like if I had to if I had to look
at it comparatively would I take a woman
with a child over a woman that was more
problematic problematic but no child I
probably go for the one that's more
problematic just because at least I can
make the mistakes with her instead of
having to carry on someone else's
baggage do you feel like you can the the
quote unquote things that you don't like
you know you feel like that's more
malleable whereas like you're saying
like the child like the child's there
like that's it yeah yeah because that's
something irreversible that I can't
change would you say the same thing
as in what would I take more problematic
with no child and I'll be honest if I
was looking to like settle down and have
kids now I would
have a chance to shoot
I would take I would take the more
problematic if I feel that we could work
together but I feel like a lot of men
surprise themselves like I feel like
sometimes as well like you don't know
what you would do until you're in that
situation that's even us I'll put my
I'll put my hands up right I've dated
single months before and
day treatment better than single girls
oh single mothers are lit they [ __ ]
know
what's the difference
especially if they have sons yeah
because well they take care of the
taking care of the nurturing
you're so submissive yeah
they know they have less leverage yeah
for that reason because I know
intrinsically that the only reason
you're that way is because of the
mistakes you've made okay so what's
wrong with that I don't want that why I
don't want it but why well I I pick
why would that picture
analogies coming again
all the qualities you want in a woman
she has it but just because she has
experience or a child that's not a small
thing and a child that's what you're
saying you won't maybe not no way but
you date her I'm a Nigerian man as well
you're a Nigerian uh no you're not damn
okay it was a bumper Club yeah I think I
think what this highlights is that how
women see
a woman with the child and how men look
at it is completely different like where
we're so easy with being with getting
with a guy that has a child
the expenses don't fall on us yeah true
so I was going to say that about how
women could maybe not initially I don't
think they would aim to go for a guy
with a child but I think if they fell in
love and got to know a guy
yeah
it's in our pockets yeah well it's an
attraction trigger for women so like men
are biologically predispositioned to be
repulsed by other people's kids that's
why they have this reaction to it wow
yeah because historically what would
they do they'd take the women and kill
the kids
like if one it would be tribes so if one
tribe conquered the other tribe it goes
back to what I was saying earlier like
where women would end up with the best
male yes so if one tribe conquered the
other tribe they would take the fertile
women okay they would take the the they
might they might take a girls if she's
old enough but they kill the kids
anyway and a big reason of that they had
a yeah it's not it's not good it's just
yeah I think it's a big reason that
comes back to what you said is as a man
if you're going to choose a woman who
has kids then the responsibility of the
child often falls on you and the truth
is like I said we're selfish by Design
right the reason that we kill the kids
back in the day was because as a man he
it was his job to put his life on the
line for the family and best believe if
you spend his life online for his family
he's doing it for his own kin and not
someone else and women like men with
kids because historically if he had a
kid that was a sign of pre-selection he
could take care of other women yeah it's
a sign of responsibility actually also
another fun fact is
um felons have 30 more kids than
non-felons so when women say they're
like nice guys cap
[Laughter]
um okay I'm gonna take a second and read
the super chats okay guys
um also as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible